[Musica]
[Applauso]
oggi parliamo di fallimento che brutta
parola fallimento
una parola che ci fa venire alla mente
ansia disagio paura fallimento la parola
che se guardiamo le anche la sua
etimologia all'etimologia latina dal
verbo faller che è in inganno al
fallimento in che senso
inganno le due cose non guardano
pensiamo anche alla parola fallace
inganno perché il fallimento è un
inganno un momento in cui noi crediamo
che le cose vadano in un certo modo e
poi scopriamo che vanno nella maniera
completamente diversa quindi in qualche
modo che noi troviamo una realtà che
disattesa da quelle che sono le nostre
aspettative soprattutto è anche un
momento in cui noi creiamo una nostra
maschera
noi ci creiamo sentiamo perfettamente
organizzati perfettamente equipaggiati
per affrontare una sfida ma poi quando
arriva il momento della sfida cadiamo e
quindi è anche una caduta la caduta di
una maschera che noi ci siamo
ci siamo fatti e chiaro che il successo
è qualcosa di gratificante il fallimento
non lo è ma il fallimento accende molto
spesso il sacro fuoco quello che non lo
saprò fuoco perché dal fallimento che si
impara da successo ci si gratifica ma
dal fallimento si impara e quello che
oggi vorrei portarvi un po un paio di
esperienze di fallimento che mi
riguardano personalmente in particolare
per quello che è il lavoro che faccio mi
occupo di fibre di carbonio fibre di
carbonio è un molti di voi sanno che
cos'è
però credo pochi sanno chi è che la
scoperta scoperta un grande scienziato
americano thomas edison nella seconda
metà dell'ottocento sta facendo una
serie di esperimenti che riguardavano
trovare il materiale adatto per per la
sua lampadina e in tutti questi
esperimenti si imbatte in una fibra che
aveva delle caratteristiche strepitose
che nessuno aveva mai
ma è scoperto prima forse non l'ha
capito l'idea del giusto peso ma sta di
fatto che per arrivare alla fibra di
carbonio e poi al tungsteno che nel
materiale che lui in realtà stava
cercando edison test o qualcosa come 10
mila materiali diversi e un giornalista
che voleva provocarlo un giornalista del
new york time nel 1879 gli chiese ma
come mai hai fatto 10 mila test e non
sei arrivata niente altri giornalisti
ben informati che fanno questo tipo di
domande ed eddy sono un po piccato disse
non ho fallito 10.000 volte soltanto
trovato 10.000 modi per cui questa cosa
non funziona quindi la gestione del
fallimento edison è un messaggio che mi
piace molto e per il quale ci tenevo
moltissimo portarvelo perché è un
messaggio che si applica molto bene
l'ingegneria al ramo di cui io mi occupo
10.000 fallimenti sono un modo per
capire quali sono le strade che non devi
percorrere quali sono le vie che non
deve intraprendere e diciamo uno di
questi esempi che gli sta molto cuore è
un esempio che che vorrei portare nelle
nostre vetture
io lavoro per lamborghini nelle nostre
vetture conta tantissimo i dei dati che
sono incontrovertibili o sei dentro quei
dati non lo sei nessuno o sei nel club
dei tre secondi sullo 0 100 o non c'è
nessuno o sei con il tempo al
nurburgring il più veloce con lo sa
nessuno
ora il rapporto peso potenza giusto o
non sei nessuno
e allora non ci misuriamo costantemente
con questi parametri costantemente siamo
a rischio di fallimento per quelli che
sono le aspettative che i nostri che i
nostri clienti hanno in un progetto
qualche anno fa appena arrivai
lamborghini mi resi conto che cosa
voleva dire imparare dal fallimento
perché avevamo iniziato erano già
vent'anni che lamborghini lavorato a
quella fibra di carbonio però in quegli
anni le normative erano cambiate ero
diventata sempre più severe ma girate
quello che è successo il mondo
automotive e negli ultimi vent'anni e ma
forse anche sugli ultimi 15 anni e
normativo sono diventate strettissime e
questo è un dato naturalmente a
vantaggio della sicurezza dei nostri
passeggeri
però allora era la prima volta che
avevamo iniziato a usare il composito
per un uso strutturale e quindi ci
trovavamo a non capire bene quelle che
erano le dinamiche dei crash sapete che
la vettura devono essere devo fare dei
crash per essere omologate e quindi
all'inizio avevamo avuto un pò qualche
mal di pancia perché non riuscivamo a
trovare quello che era la quadra per
arrivare a superare i cresce alla fine
grazie all'esperienza che avevamo
comunque già da una ventina d'anni
materiali compositi ma anche grazie al
nostro consenso siamo riusciti ad
arrivare ma come ingegneri non eravamo
contenti per noi era stato un piccolo un
piccolo fallimento così non erano stati
contenti perché non eravamo riusciti a
stare nei tempi che volevamo nei paesi
che volevamo e anche nei costi
dunque che cosa potevamo fare fallimento
non deve generare l'inazione la non
azione o peggio ancora quando è la sfida
dopo abbasso quella che è la mia la mia
aspettativa di co fallito la prima volta
la seconda un po più conservativo così
non mi sbaglio no quello che abbiamo
fatto è stato riorganizzarci
ristrutturarci metterci la corazza
accendere quello che saprò fuoco quello
che di cui vi parlavo prima
e siamo arrivati al progetto dopo
abbiamo pensato di non abbassare
l'asticella ma di alzarla abbiamo detto
va bene al primo progetto abbiamo usato
poco carbonio e secondo noi usiamo
tantissimo ma non potevamo essere
incoscienti
dovevamo ristrutturarci riorganizzarci e
fare in modo che avremmo potuto
affrontare quella nuova sfida con gli
strumenti che erano quelli che ci
servivano per affrontarla con successo e
nacque così il progetto vento
ma come potevamo ristrutturarci su
qualcosa che conoscevamo ma la pena è la
chiave per il successo è stata per noi
quella di andare dai maestri dalla
boeing cioè di capire e di andare a
parlare con quelli che conoscevano
meglio di noi
il materiale composito quindi l'umiltà
di saper dire nel fallimento non so lo
so poco o forse credo di sapere ma non
proprio come dovrei ci siamo
riorganizzati e stato per noi un po come
andare a scuola un'altra volta perché
questi erano i professori in quel campo
e quindi loro ci hanno aperto il libro
ci hanno spiegato quello che in era una
logica si chiama pi li blocca project
che è la chiave per il successo nel
materiali compositi e siamo poi arrivati
a fare un progetto per noi ingegneri
vincente che quello prima non lo fosse
ma questo è stato però il progetto che
ci ha dato soddisfazione perché quando
siamo andati affari cresce
siamo arrivati a farne uno solo per ogni
caso omologativo abbiamo aperto poi un
altro laboratorio sia per l'università
di washington che dobbiamo poi iniziato
finalmente a capire quelli che hanno i
problemi dinamici dell'impiego dei
materiali compositi
ecco questo è un esempio che gli piace
portarvi che nella nostra vita
professionale ho avuto anche un esempio
nella mia vita personale perché quando
avevo 18 anni mi sono diplomata al liceo
classico con il massimo dei voti
studente modello bacio della commissione
una cosa meravigliosa arrivo cui pieno
di aspettative
ero sicurissimo in scrivo di ingegneria
bellissimo questa facoltà meravigliosa
arrivo carico tutto bello con il mio
zainetto i primi sei mesi ho preso tanti
di quelle legnate che veramente io non
capivo che cosa stessero dicendo per me
era ostrogoto questi strani individui
che parlava non facevo delle cose della
lavagna ho fatto sei mesi ero veramente
ridotto che in questo modo qua e allora
ho detto cosa faccio allora quando sei
davanti al fallimento rai due strade o
non agisce quindi nasce la paura la non
azione
la paura il blocco quello di cui
parlavamo prima
oppure accendi sacro fuoco e oggi sono
qui evidentemente questa tecnica
funziona
quindi mi piace come dire parlare anche
quella che gli americani definiscono
alla fine un respiro il fatto che loro
non hanno paura di parlare dei loro
fallimenti del loro esperienze
fallimentari se fate un colloquio negli
stati uniti chiedono
parlaci della tua esperienza dei tuoi
fallimenti ma cosa stranissima in italia
quando te lo chiedono attenti sempre a
dare una risposta un po edulcorata lo
attenti sempre a dare una risposta che
sia in qualche modo che ti porti poi a
far vedere che si ho fallito però poi
sono riuscito invece in america è
assolutamente normale parlare dei propri
fallimenti senza necessariamente dover
dare un risvolto positivo ho fallito
quella volta perché appunto e questa è
la fede lo respinse quindi vorrei
lasciarvi oggi un po sempre con
l'esempio che ci ha dato a thomas edison
a suo tempo il successo è certamente
individuare una strada e seguirla è
arrivarci fino in fondo ma la chiave di
questo sta anche in tanti piccoli
insuccessi perché il successo è anche
capire quelle che sono le strade che non
portano a niente che se stesse però sono
parte importante del successo grazie
[Applauso]